[Musica]
ciao sono gianluigi ho 45 anni da 20
anni mi occupo di comunicazione digitale
ma le mie figlie non sono online allora
la mia storia che che voglio raccontarvi
parte da molto lontano talmente lontano
che è l'altra parte del mondo in uno zoo
di hong kong durante la pandemia due
panda si sono accoppiati dopo dieci anni
del resto non c'erano dei turisti
intorno e vorrei vedere voi del resto a
a copiarvi con dei panda che vi fissano
quindi una bellissima notizia ha fatto
il giro del mondo talmente interessante
che è stata commentata dappertutto ma un
commento in particolare mi è piaciuto
ed è questo avete fatto bene ad oscurare
le facce in effetti se riguardiamo sono
state pixel a te le facce dei panda e io
ho pensato ma che strana specie che
siamo noi umani pixel chiamo e
preserviamo la privacy dei panda ma non
ci preoccupiamo della privacy dei nostri
figli
queste immagini io le ho prese in una
brevissima sessione di navigazione su
instagram
e questo è un fenomeno che si sta
veramente diffondendo a macchia d'olio e
soprattutto si è acuito durante il lock
down
perché questo fenomeno che si chiama
vetrinizzazione sociale cioè noi viviamo
in vetrina è stato in qualche modo
amplificato all'ennesima potenza perché
non avevamo più la possibilità di
fotografare i nostri soggetti preferiti
quindi la pizza in pizzeria oppure il i
viaggi oppure la gita fuori porta oppure
il nostro lavoro e allora abbiamo
fotografato sempre di più noi genitori i
nostri figli
eravamo chiusi nelle nostre case e
fotografano i nostri figli
solo che a un certo punto io racconto
queste cose quando vado in giro per le
scuole una volta durante una sessione in
una scuola in una scuola media si alza
dal fondo della classe una mano e un
bambino mi chiede un ragazzo mi chiede
ma mi scusi ma i bambini hanno diritto
alla privacy
io ho detto certo sono esseri umani come
noi fa no perché secondo me sono tutti
uguali e quindi chi li distingue uno
dall'altro detto beh strano dai secondo
me i diritti bambini hanno diritto
assolutamente alla privacy ma vi
racconto un piccolo aneddoto una volta
vado in piscina porto in piscina la mia
figlia grande ea un certo punto
orgoglioso per quello che
stava facendo durante appunto
l'allenamento prendo il mio cellulare la
fotografo e mandola foto a casa con
whatsapp dopo un po beep beep arriva un
messaggio di mia moglie laura che mi
dice qualcosa che mi ha lasciato
veramente perplesso la frase era questa
quella non è nostra figlia l'ho guardata
bene
effettivamente non era lei ma
soprattutto ho cercato di abbozzare
dicendo e rispondendo massida e la
taglia più o meno è quella la cuffia e
quella in realtà avevo fatto la
condivisione di foto dei figli altrui
resto comunque dell'idea secondo me che
i bambini non sono tutti uguali e che
abbiano diritto alla privacy
questa cosa evidentemente non è così per
tutti i genitori soprattutto perché ci
sono dei genitori che stanno
condividendo degli scatti dei propri
figli che sono secondo me un po
esagerati in questo caso per esempio si
celebrava la diciamo la fine dell'uso
del del vasino per poi andare nel nel
battere però diventa un immagine molto
molto particolare e mi sono chiesto ma i
genitori di questa bambina avranno
chiesto a lei il permesso
statisticamente no perché la 88 per
cento dei genitori che condividono le
foto dei propri figli online non chiede
il permesso
88 per cento 8 su 9 sono veramente
veramente tanti
c'è qualcuno che magari all'accortezza
anche se è un momento intimo di metterci
qualche pezzettino qualche tipo di
sticker copre comunque le parti intime
peccato che in questo caso nella foto è
stata coperta una parte intima non è
stata coperto il volto ci ho pensato io
ma quello che mi lascia un po perplesso
è un hashtag pisellino ho scoperto che
ci sono un sacco di fotografie online
con hashtag pisellino e questo diventa
un pochettino problematico ma non c'è
solo pisellino abbiamo anche le chipette
per i diversamente milanesi dovete
sapere che le ciapet sono delle piccole
natiche allora io voglio in qualche modo
mettere in guardia tutti i genitori che
dovessero condividere le foto dei propri
figli con l'astag ciapet che esiste è
usato 789 mila volte perché non dovete
fare una cosa del genere perché le
vostre foto finirebbero in mezzo a delle
ciapet un po diverse
molto molto diverse quindi sarà
un po problematico detto questo le
vostre foto finirebbero in un diciamo
social network come instagram per
esempio che premia le foto di nudo cioè
l'algoritmo di instagram a premi a
quanta pelle tu stai mostrando quanta
quantità quanta percentuale di pelle più
6 nudo e più mostra quell'immagine
volete veramente che le foto dei vostri
figli finiscano in un ambiente del
genere
beh tutto questo quello che vi sto
raccontando un nome è un fenomeno
talmente consolidato che si chiama ceren
thing è una parola che abbiamo dovuto
inventarci perché il fenomeno non
esisteva fino a un po di tempo fa prima
dei social prima degli smartphone
cerentin una parola inglese formata
dalla crasi di altre due parole share
condivisione parenting genitorialità
genitori che sovraespongono i propri
figli
online è una cosa che si è talmente
diffusa che ormai parte da molto molto
prima che il bambino nasca c'è una serie
di immagini con l'asta ecografia che fa
impressione ed effettivamente in alcuni
casi ho dovuto io mettere anche qui la
pecetta per il povero bambino
protagonista ancora nella pancia
ovviamente non tutto lo share hunting è
dannoso in questo caso per esempio i
genitori hanno avuto l'accortezza di
rispettare la privacy sia del figlio che
del kiwi e questa è una cosa positiva ma
qui arriviamo allo chez ranking vip
perché fino adesso abbiamo raccontato
storie normali di persone e questo ci
mettiamo il vip ci mettiamo gwyneth
paltrow una delle più importanti delle
attrici hollywoodiane americane che a un
certo punto va in vacanza con la sua
famiglia va in vacanza si fanno un self
e pubblica questa foto su instagram è un
tripudio ovviamente di like quanto siete
belle come siete carine però a un certo
punto andando bene a leggere tra tutti i
commenti sotto la foto di gwyneth
paltrow si legge il commento di una
ragazza che si chiama apple martin che è
la figlia di gwyneth paltrow che dice
mamma ne abbiamo parlato un sacco di
volte non puoi postare le cose senza il
mio permesso
nove su dieci non chiedono il permesso
anche in questo caso come ho fatto io
quella volta in piscina o cerca ha
cercato di abbozzare anche lei dicendo
sì dai non ti si vede nemmeno la faccia
ma è un problema di rispetto è un
problema che la ragazza non voleva
essere lì e lei ha diritto alla sua
identità digitale e quindi ha bisogno di
essere rispettata non sempre così
addirittura si mette in ridicolo i
propri figli in questo caso per esempio
probabilmente i genitori hanno pensato
che fosse divertente questa immagine
però secondo me stanno un po segnando la
vita e la reputazione digitale di questo
bambino che probabilmente da grande
troverà sicuramente lavoro in una ditta
di pannolini o di spurghi ma magari
altrove si sentirà in imbarazzo
soprattutto perché una foto del genere
può diventare virale ed è diventata
virale e quindi la reputazione ripeto
del bambino in qualche modo forse un po
compromessa ma vi voglio raccontare
anche un'altra un altro piccolo aneddoto
qualche anno fa si era diffusa la madre
ruth challenge la sfida delle madri
bisognava testimoniare la propria
maternità le proprie esperienze di mamma
di neo mamma con delle fotografie intime
una cosa che ha avuto un successo
clamoroso si è diffusa in tutto il mondo
c'erano un sacco un sacco di immagini
online di madri e di figli ea un certo
punto in italia è dovuta intervenire la
polizia postale due punti mamme attente
a postare i vostri figli su facebook
perché stava diventando un problema
anche di sicurezza dei bambini di furto
di identità di furto di immagini non
tutti erano d'accordo
a un certo punto delle mamme hanno
cominciato a contestare questa cosa
mamma giovanna per esempio dice ma
davvero credete che non postare foto
possa essere utile per fermare la
pedofilia
io questa cosa non la so però so
un'altra cosa
vi racconto un altro piccolo aneddoto
della mia carriera dieci anni fa fino a
dieci anni fa facevo giornalista
professionista in un'altra vita
praticamente a un certo punto per
parlare di tecnologia mi invita la
guardia di finanza mia vita per fare
un'intervista si stavamo parlando di
altro era la pirateria ve non so se vi
ricordate i tempi di napster parlavamo
di quelle cose lì innocue tutto sommato
a un certo punto il
gli i miei interlocutori mi dicono vini
di là ti facciamo vedere quello che
abbiamo sequestrato ieri durante
un'operazione contro la pedopornografia
e detto no fa niente lasciamo stare
come se l'avessi come se avessi
accettato no lo devi vedere non lo
voglio vedere se lo devi vedere non lo
voglia vedere me l'hanno fatto vedere io
all'epoca non avevo figlie adesso noi
due all'epoca non ne avevo ma io quella
notte non ho dormito perché ho scoperto
che questi malintenzionati si scambiano
le immagini che hanno etichettato e
mettono le tichetti na bagnetto tutina
mare e molto molto peggio che non posso
raccontare
ecco questa cosa mi abbia
particolarmente particolarmente
sconvolto perché poi ho scoperto che una
rivi una in australia è stato fatto uno
studio su questo il 50 per cento delle
foto trovate nei database dei pedofili e
vediamo noi una foto su due era nostra e
ne abbiamo completamente perso il
controllo questa cosa mi ha fatto stare
male e ho pensato ai flinstones bristol
che cosa c'entrano parte dovete
apprezzare il fatto che anche in questo
caso i minorenni
li ho coperti io con una pecetta ma
perché ho pensato ai flinstones ho
pensato ai nostri antenati perché dal
punto di vista evoluzionistico dal punto
di vista naturale
i genitori devono essere gli angeli
custodi dei propri figli perché hanno
trasmesso il proprio patrimonio genetico
nei figli e devono proteggerli e invece
allora da questo punto di vista c'è
qualcosa che non va e allora lo share
hunting è contro natura è un black out
dal punto di vista evoluzionistico non
può funzionare e le conseguenze possono
essere come abbiamo visto molto gravi ma
non è molto diverso da quando vediamo
sfrecciare nelle strade delle nostre
città queste macchine con il sul lunotto
posteriore i nomi di tutti i componenti
della famiglia
anche questo forse è pericoloso perché è
un malintenzionato potrebbe andare dalla
piccola vanessa e dire guarda tua mamma
alessia e tua sorella anastasia ci
aspettano lì al bar ti stanno aspettando
vieni con noi questa cosa mi fa mi fa
stare abbastanza male quindi lo share
enti non si può mai fare
no sarebbe assurdo sono io il primo a
scattare circa 4 5 600 foto delle mie
due bambine tutti i santi mesi e ogni
tanto le condivido
ma a determinate condizioni e allora c'è
questo mantra che gira in rete che share
with her condividi avendo cura di
rispettare i tuoi figli la loro privacy
e allora secondo me bisogna avere cura
di prima di tutto avere buon senso e
quindi quando facciamo gli scatti dei
nostri figli magari non inquadriamo nei
momenti imbarazzanti e soprattutto
magari noi inquadriamo il loro volto
oppure noi abbiamo degli strumenti
straordinari come gli smartphone che
sono pieni di magie tecnologiche che ci
permettono quantomeno tecnicamente di
inserire una pecetta una pixelatura
tutto quello che possiamo fare per
progetti proteggerli dobbiamo farlo
esistono anche degli strumenti specifici
per esempio family album tra gli altri
in parte gratuito consente di
condividere in tutta sicurezza e con chi
vogliamo noi
le immagini dei nostri figli
allora in conclusione di questo discorso
io vorrei tornare ai nostri mitici panda
in questo caso anche qui sono stato io
ho fatto un gran lavoro è permettere
pecette dappertutto ci ho perso un sacco
di tempo per metterle dappertutto ma il
messaggio che io voglio lanciare è
assolutamente questo noi per i nostri
figli
siamo un esempio pensate se un giorno
mia figlia alla quale ho appena detto
non devi condividere troppe immagini non
devi condividere troppe informazioni e
video di te stessa pensate se lei mi
guardasse mi dicesse ma come papa fino a
ieri hai usato la mia faccia per
raccattare 4 like in più e adesso io non
posso usarla per me stessa non sta in
piedi
dobbiamo essere degli esempi ma
soprattutto quello che voglio dire che
oltre ogni limite è uno slogan secondo
me meraviglioso e lo dico da
imprenditore però secondo me quando
parliamo delle foto e delle informazioni
dei nostri figli
qualche limite dovremo tenerlo grazie
[Applauso]